I want to show you a cartoonish video of a
Trump official talking out of both sides of
his mouth.
And then I want to have a serious conversation
and actually try to talk about facts.
This is video of Donald Trump, Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo.
He went or Pompeo, as some call him.
He went on a._b._c.s this week, over the weekend
with Martha RADDATZ.
And during 30 seconds, this is 30 seconds.
He said, yes, coronavirus was manmade.
No, corona virus was not manmade.
This is the same guy.
This is the same day.
This is the same interview.
This is the same 30 to second segment, completely
incoherent.
Take a look at this.
It was manmade or genetically modified.
The best expert so far seem to think it was
manmade.
I've no reason to disbelieve that at this
point.
If you're at your office of the DNI says the
consensus, the scientific consensus was not
manmade or genetically modified.
That's right.
I agree with that.
I've said I've seen their analysis.
I've seen the summary that you saw that was
released publicly.
I have no reason to doubt that that is accurate.
Now, I have no reason to disbelieve.
It was manmade.
And my office is correct that it's not manmade.
That is direct conflict.
OK, you if you haven't been following this.
Donald Trump and others have been talking
about whether Corona virus, instead of simply
coming from bats, jumping to humans and then
spreading, if it might have been a project
of a level for biosafety laboratory in Wuhan,
China, and could have escaped because of a
mistake, or maybe it was even released deliberately
like a bio weapon.
Now, there are some fringe conspiracy theories
that insist that it was a deliberately released
manmade bioweapon.
That's I mean, I'm not even gonna take that
seriously because there's no evidence of that.
There have been some reports that have jumped
to relatively mainstream corporate media,
which say it's being looked at, not whether
it was manmade, but whether it was naturally
occurring, but was being studied in the lab
and through an accident came out of the lab.
Okay.
Now, I just want to make sure we're clear
on the possibilities we're talking about and
the ones that we are not.
So the possibilities are this came from bats
and was transmitted in public through natural
means.
It came from bats, was being studied in this
lab and was accidentally released.
It came from bats, was studied in the lab
and was deliberately released.
It was completely manmade, but released accidentally.
And then, of course, it was completely manmade
and released on purpose as a bio weapon.
I'm only talking about scenarios 1 and 2,
which is if this was being studied at this
lab, it was released as an accident due to
a mistake.
The reason we are even having this conversation
is because there actually have been some reports
saying that this is being looked at.
Countless scientific sources have already
identified that it is of natural origin that
wouldn't precluded from having been studied
at this Wu Han lab.
And that's the reason that we're bringing
it out.
Now, what is a biosafety level 4 lab, anyway?
What we're talking about is the one institute
of virology.
This has been around since 2015.
Biosafety level 4 is when you were working
with easily transmissible, transmissible pathogens
which can often be transmitted via aerosol
and which can cause human death.
If a human is infected, often there would
be no treatment or vaccination if a human
were to be infected.
That's the level lab that they have in Wunan
and there's a whole bunch of other technical
requirements if you are level 4.
So my position is before we know for sure
at this point, it appears that this is a naturally
occurring corona virus that came originally
from bats transmitted in public.
I'm open to the idea that it may have been
a pathogen being researched in this lab.
If we have evidence of that, then we'll take
it more seriously.
As of right now, I don't believe that that
was the case.
I don't believe it was a bio weapon or released
on purpose.
But here's the serious thing to consider,
OK?
If this was something being researched in
this corona, in this one lab in China and
it was released accidentally, it changes nothing
of of Donald Trump's response to the Corona
virus.
If it was completely naturally transmitted,
the United States and South Korea had their
first cases within hours of each other.
South Korea handled it properly and the United
States did not.
South Korea's death rate is 5 people per million.
The U.S. death rate is 210 people per million.
You didn't mishear that.
Our death rate per population is 42 times
that of South Korea's.
So if this was mishandled at the Wuhan lab
and accidentally released, that must be researched.
That must be dealt with.
And within China, there are already fears
of a backlash like the one seen because of
the Tiananmen Square incident.
We'll talk about that on the bonus show.
If that's the case, there will be backlash.
We all know that.
But it doesn't make a difference in terms
of evaluating Trump's handling.
If it spread at a woolen wet market, Trump's
response was terrible.
If it came accidentally being released from
a one level for biosafety lab, Trump's response
was still terrible.
It's a very important thing that we not allow
the story about the source to.
Distract from our federal government's failed
response.
And from Donald Trump's constant lies and
attacks and smears as a result of the virus.
We'll follow the story.
We'll take it where it leads us.
It does nothing to make Donald Trump's response
anything
but completely
a bizarre